après sur la question des grandes
entreprises
les gens qui sont à la tête des grandes
entreprises ont malgré tout des
responsabilités importantes
alors nous ce qu'on considère en tant
que représentants des pme c'est qu'il
n'assume pas le risque de manière
directe contrairement à un chef
d'entreprise de pme qui responsable sur
ses biens propres bon déjà il ya là
quelque chose une véritable différence
et puis après quand on parle très fortes
rémunérations il ya certes les grandes
entreprises mais peut-être qu'on
pourrait parler aussi j'ai pas entendu
d'autres métiers qui gagnent beaucoup
d'argent vous avez parlé des animateurs
de télévision moi je trouve ça très bien
que les gens talentueux gagne de
l'argent on pourrait parler des joueurs
de foot qui a énormément d'argent et
c'est très bien tant mieux pour eux et
créent de la richesse je pense que
mettre tout le monde à la même toise
c'est une erreur ça serait démotivant et
quand vous êtes même quand vous gagnez
le smic de savoir qu'il ya des gens qui
gagnent davantage et qu'un jour
peut-être vous gagnerez aussi davantage
c'est quelque chose qui est plutôt
motivant et alors après sur la question
du smic je crois que là aussi il ya
l'idée généreuse en soi qui est de dire
que avec le cynique on vit mal et je
partage tout à fait 7 à 10 je pense
notamment dans la région parisienne
c'est extrêmement compliqué de vivre
avec un smic et ça doit être
effectivement très compliqué au
quotidien maintenant ce qu'il faut
savoir également c'est que quand vous
augmenter le smic vous impacter la
compétitivité encore une fois des
entreprises et il ya des chiffres qui
sont pas les miens qui sont de 2 lots
fce qui disent que quand vous augmenter
le smic de 1 % on considère que vous
détruisez mécaniquement plus de 25000
emplois en face et qui sont des emplois
c'est le paradoxe de gens qui sont les
moins qualifiés donc vous êtes sur
quelque chose de généreux tout le monde
peut dire oui on va augmenter le smic
bravoure on applaudit dans la pratique
malheureusement encore une fois c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué que simplement
raisonner avec des indicateurs
[Musique]